so  i'll fight everybody  this started with me calling out  mcgregor and people were like oh that  kid's crazy  mcgregor would kill him  and now it's like  that fight could happen in the next 24  months 100 it probably will and i will  beat him so people just like  are seeing how serious i am about this  and  changing the way they think about it is  that mcgregor conversation happening  yeah it's been happening for for a while  you know we're talking to his team and  it makes sense you know he wanted me to  get more fights under my belt  and  build up my name build up my  pay-per-view buys and that's exactly  what i've done  so  you know we're coming to that crossroad  very shortly